le président giscard d'estaing pour le
centenaire de la république les
institutions juste équilibre entre
l'exécutif et le législatif du soleil
dans votre maison chaque jour le rôle du
commissariat à l'énergie solaire dans la
vie quotidienne ni juge ni partie le
conciliateur avec nous nelly bonheur
comptait des onglets dans la crise une
monnaie convalescente mais une économie
toujours malade
messieurs bonsoir j - 17 dans 17 jours
en effet les jeux seront faits ont en
tout cas à moitié fait puisque cela
correspondra à la fermeture des derniers
bureaux des votes du premier tour
aujourd'hui le fait saillant de la
campagne et bien ce sont les propos que
le chef de l'état tenus en inaugurant
une exposition aux archives nationales
une exposition consacrée à 100 ans de
république
l'occasion pour valérie clavé stade de
se pencher sur le rôle du président de
la république sur ses rapports avec le
gouvernement et le parlement
autant de sujets bien sûr plus que
jamais d'actualité au début de la
troisième république
comme pendant la cinquième république il
y a eu un bon équilibre entre le pouvoir
exécutif et le pouvoir législatif il n'y
a pas eu de confusion entre les deux le
gouvernement gouverner et votre par le
parlement légiférer et c'est un des fous
croire des règles fondamentales
si l'on veut assurer le progrès la
république en france ce qu'il y est à la
fois un bon équilibre et une bonne
distinction entre la fonction de faire
les lois et la fonction de conduire la
politique de la france
chaque fois au contraire que la
république a glissé vers le régime
d'assemblée pour une pause ou pour une
autre
la république est affaiblie et la france
avec m c'est pourquoi je considère qu'il
est très important pour l'avenir de la
france dans sa vie politique et dans son
rayonnement extérieur que nous retenions
cette grande leçon républicaine qui est
celle que nous devons avoir en france
une république solide qui soit le bien
de tous les français et dont les
institutions repose sur un juste
équilibre entre la responsabilité de
ceux qui gouvernent et la responsabilité
de ceux qui font les lois et puisque la
république quel bien des français
il appartient au président de la
république de préserver nos institutions
républicaines
j'ai indiqué à plusieurs reprises que
j'attachais à cette fonction une part
essentielle dans mes responsabilités et
je ferai en sorte que les institutions
républicaines que la france soit de ces
données restent toujours le cadre de son
progrès et de sa liberté alors ses
propres ailes copains sont bien dans la
ligne de ce qui s'est toujours dit sous
la vème république
oui je crois qu'il ya deux points
essentiels qui apparaissent clairement
qu'ils sont à retenir a souligné le
premier point le premier principe le
président est le garant des institutions
c'est effectivement la première tâche
d'ailleurs que lui assigne la
constitution et monsieur giscard
d'estaing se plaçant autrefois dans
l'hypothèse où la gauche l'emporterait
avait dit qu'il resterait quoi qu'il
arrive et qu'il resterait pour être le
gardien des institutions il le répète de
façon claire aujourd'hui et comme vous
lisiez c'est bien d'actualité
deuxièmement deuxième principe la
séparation et l'équilibré du pouvoir
pouvoir exécutif et pouvoir législatif
c'était par action devrait dire n'est
pas totale dans notre système parce que
chacun des pouvoirs un peu une arme
contre l'autre le pouvoir législatif
l'assemblée nationale en tout cas peut
renverser le gouvernement qui lui est
nommé par le président de la république
est le prénom la république lui lieu
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale c'est
pourquoi le général de gaulle et georges
pompidou aimait répéter que notre
système était un système ni présidentiel
ni parlementaire l'on avait l'impression
pendant les premières années du mandat
de monsieur giscard d'estaing et qu'il
avait tendance à insister sur ce qu'il
appelait lui-même le présidentialisme
c'est un mot qui l'avait lancé dans une
interview à jacques chancel il ya deux
ans près c'est ma mère est ce que c'est
compatible avec ce qu'il a dit à verdun
sur le doubs c'est à dire que le chef de
l'état n'a aucun moyen de s'opposer à
l'application du prince
malta déchirant eh bien oui cette phrase
de verdun sur le doubs avait donné
l'impression que précisément le
président de la république se
contenterait s'il avait une majorité de
gauche à l'assemblée nationale se
contenterait d'être le gardien des
institutions et ne pourrait pas
intervenir dans la politique qu'il
renoncerait ce qu'on appelle dans
l'esprit de la vème république
la définition des grandes orientations
de la politique française
en gros on paraissait s'éloigner un peu
du présidentialisme et le plateau de la
balance entre les deux pouvoirs semblait
pencher du côté du législatif et
aujourd'hui je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
dire que il y à une correction de tir
la déclaration du président la
république et quand même d'une autre
tonalité
en effet le président condamne très
nettement comme il l'avait déjà fait
d'ailleurs dans le passé ce qu'il
appelle le régime d'assemblée le rhume
d'assemblée c'est celui où le pouvoir
exécutif émane de l'assemblée nationale
alors que dans la vème république le
gouvernement émane du président de la
république même si l'onf a semblé
nationale peut le renverser
alors même si le président de la
république ne le dit pas ce soir comment
cet équilibre peut être maintenue il
affirme au moins la fois la nécessité et
sa volonté de le maintenir
politique toujours françois mitterrand à
france inter ce soir a répété qu'il ne
sait pas question pour le ps
d'actualisation pour le programme sur le
3 mai prochain avant le 19 mars toujours
à france inter mais ce matin raymond
barre a déploré le dépôt de candidature
sauvage de dernière minute par les
formations de la majorité
il a aussi regretté que quinze membres
de son gouvernement se voit opposer un
concurrent au sein de cette majorité
un nouveau groupe de réflexion dialogue
socialiste qui se veut une sorte de
passerelle entre des membres du ps
d'hénin engagé et des partisans de la
majorité
et puis la politique c'est aussi cette
somme de livres que nous recevons chaque
jour
en voici quelques-uns jean marie benoît
et nouveau primaire vous le connaissiez
déjà giscard de tous les jours par
joseph jarre jonas et a nourri dans le
même style la vie quotidienne à l'elysée
autant de valéry giscard d'estaing notre
confrère pierre pélissier dans la même
collection chez hachette la vie
quotidienne au palais bourbon à la fin
la troisième république par andré guérin
le confrère
et puis le dictionnaire des 10000
dirigeants politiques français accor cnp
ce syndicat ce matin sur l'indemnisation
du chômage partiel il s'agissait de
reconduire pour un an encore un accord
qui date de trois ans maintenant les
salariés mise en chômage partiel
continueront à percevoir la moitié de
leur salaire pour toutes les heures
perdues en dessous de 40 heures par
semaine et l'indemnisation minimale
passe à 965 c'est-à-dire un tout petit
peu en dessous du smic
tous les grands syndicats ont signé
aussi qu'il faut revenir sur cette
décision du conseil des ministres d'hier
la création d'un commissariat à
l'énergie solaire
une initiative qui redonne un peu
confiance à ceux qui croient dans
l'avenir de cette énergie de
remplacement
voici temi centrale solaire française en
construction dans la dans les pyrénées à
targassonne
ce sont des miroirs qui renvoient la
lumière du soleil vers une chaudière
voici une autre centrale solaire
française type bertin celle ci sera
construite en corse plus de miroirs ici
mais des tubes qui chauffent au soleil
quelle est la meilleure technique vient
aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas ce sera
le rôle du commissariat l'énergie
solaire de noël de nous le dire il fera
la coordination entre les divers projets
qui existent mais l'énergie solaire
c'est aussi et surtout la maison la vie
quotidienne et là c'est vous qui devait
décider si oui ou non vous voulez vous
équiper avec ce type d'énergie ce
commissariat ne va pas décider pour vous
mais il peut en revanche vous aider
concrètement je vais acheter un chauffe
eau solaire
écoutez voilà autour de moi quelque
chose au solaire 1 2 3 vous voyez leur
semble tout à fait un chauffe-eau que
vous avez probablement chez vous rien de
mystérieux dans l'énergie solaire
l'énergie elle vient du toit par exemple
voici une tuile solaire elle peut
remplacer quelques tulle de votre toit à
l'intérieur de l'eau circule se
chauffent au soleil et vient alimenter
le chauffe eau soit directement soit
indirectement
vous pouvez aussi mettre cette huile
dans votre jardin quand il n'ya pas de
soleil
ces nuages sont blancs ça marche quand
même moins bien bien sûr 50% de moins de
rendement mais quand les nuages sont
vraiment noire ou la nuit
ça ne marche pas alors il faut une
énergie d'appoint à condition de l'avoir
voilà par exemple une énergie d'appoint
électrique
pas de problème vous avez d énergie
d'appoint au gaz avait au fioul
ça vous donnera quand même une idée
quand vous avez un chauffe eau solaire
prenez vos douche vauban le soir plutôt
l'eau chaude a été gardé toute la
journée soit à peine de regarder toute
la nuit
est ce que c'est possible partout en
france alors voilà une carte de france
des régions solaire de france vous
constatez deux zones
c'est de là qu'ils sont très favorisés
c'est là où vous aller en vacances
d'habitude alors y'a pas de problème
les chauffe-eau marche très bien toute
une zone au centre les chauffe-eau
marche pas mal
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
mais l'un soleil mans moyen de l'année à
toulouse à paris à strasbourg ou à brest
est pratiquement le même
et enfin dans le nord les chauffe-eau
marche aussi pas mal il faut disons plus
de surface de capteurs ce que je vais
vous dire c'est que par rapport à un
chauffe-eau classique vous fait 50%
d'économies
partout en france dans cette zone là il
en fait même 75 à 80 dans les zones très
ensoleillées et à condition de mettre un
peu plus de capteurs vous pouvez aussi
faire 50 % d'économies par rapport à
l'énergie que vous auriez dépensé dans
le nord de la france mais combien ça
coûte l'installation
alors là voilà le problème le chauffe
eau solaire est un peu plus cher que le
saut faut habituellement c'est pour ça
que le gouvernement a décidé une
subvention 1000 francs par chauffe eau
solaire acheté ou commandé en 1978 dans
certains modèles à gré pour l'instant la
commission qui agréent les modèles se
réunit on ne sait pas encore lesquels
exactement seront agréés
mais ça va venir très vite alors le prix
en gros est de l'ordre de 5000 6000
francs vous comprenez très bien que
selon la dimension du capteur selon
l'endroit où vous êtes si le ballon est
loin où le nom du capteur ça vous
coûtera un peu plus cher ou un peu moins
cher donc le prix est difficile à dire
exactement mais mille francs de
subventions c'est intéressant et pour
terminer patrick si vous le permettez un
peu de rêve
l'avenir l'électricité solaire direct
voici un panneau solaire électrique
celui là ne fait pas de la chaleur mais
de l'électricité deux applications par
exemple sur le toit de votre caravane en
vacances vous avez une batterie vous
voulez d'électricité vous voulez un peu
de deux lampes de lumière votre
transistors par exemple quand épis sont
usés ceci peut vous le fournir
que vous rouliez vous soyez arrêté son
principe est très simple
voilà un petit moteur ici notre
projecteurs l'éclair depuis tout à
l'heure ils tournent sans s'arrêter
mais si j'arrête la lumière du
projecteur c'est fini merci georges
chocolat va baisser dès la semaine
prochaine si on a décidé ce matin le
comité national des prix une baisse de
10% pour le chocolat noir et de 5% pour
le chocolat au lait baisse à la
production mais qui devrait se
répercuter chez les consommateurs mais
aussi par les bières et jambon ce matin
là ces deux produits augmenteraient mais
la décision définitive a été renvoyé à
plus tard
comme chaque soir de plus depuis plus de
trois semaines nous allons maintenant
porter notre regard sur une
circonscription dit de base nous nous
sommes promenés un petit peu partout en
france
en tout cas en métropole et il nous
manquait donc un coup d'oeil sur un
département d'outre-mer
aussi avons-nous pris l'avion pour la
guadeloupe est très vite là bas bernard
pradines aux ennemis merlin se sont
rendus compte qu'au delà des débats
métropolitain sur le smic et libertés
etc
y avait une obsession qui motive
davantage les électeurs la
départementalisation
oui ou non guadeloupe et martinique sont
ils des départements comme les autres la
réponse est dans ce sujet
c'est la politique au cinéma à
basse-terre tournage de coco lafleur
film entièrement guadeloupéens dont
l'histoire est celle de l'ambition
politique juste moment silence j'ai la
joie de vous présenter aux frères casse
nos réputés dans la réalité la
guadeloupe doit élire trois députés il y
à une vingtaine de candidats le thème
central de la campagne porte sur le
statut du département pour autrement dit
un département français de trois cent
mille habitants
mais à 7000 km de paris peut-il être
traité comme le morbihan où le pas de
calais doit-il avoir autant ou plus de
responsabilités économiques et
financiers on est quand même à 7000
kilomètres d'un métropole et quand on
regarde la distance il part un petit peu
aberrante la voix de pouvoir administrer
comme départements de métropole il est
bien certain qu'il faut quand même un
régime un peu particulier d'une compagne
d'autonomie d'indépendance et enfin
faudrait que les gens d'ici puissent
avoir un peu plus de responsabilités
qu'ils se sentent un peu responsable des
affaires du pays
il faudrait donc décidé les orientations
d'économie à paris est ici
sur ce point tous les candidats sont
d'accord mais ce n'est pas simple
l'économie de la guadeloupe n'a pas
encore décollé les seules ressources
industrielles sont en fait la banane et
la canne à sucre
comment les orienter qui doit prendre la
décision un ministre le préfet de la
guadeloupe
le conseil général ce qui renforce les
liens avec la métropole c'est le secteur
tertiaire de commerce lapan les liaisons
aériennes pas cher l'enseignement
alors ceux qui parlent d'indépendance
sont une minorité
il faut avoir des ressources des
ressources dans le sous sol des
ressources et qui proviennent de
production de manufacture ou autre et
nous ne possédons ni l'un ni l'autre
en conséquence c'est un non sens la
guadeloupe en dehors d'un état
quelconque le véritable capitale de la
guadeloupe c'est sa richesse touristique
la soufrière n'est plus menaçante la
douceur du climat et les plages de sable
fin son créateur d'emplois la promotion
économique devient prioritaire pour tous
et la lutte entre partis politiques
n'est pas la même qu'en métropole
ce sont les jeunes qui conteste comme
presque partout ailleurs mais la
majorité des électeurs votent pour ceux
qu'ils connaissent bien
où les élections'' je crois que c'est
tout à fait différent de la france parce
que la france en parle en termes de
communistes socialistes
br tandis qu'ici un député veut ne pas
avoir d'étiquette
ce qui compte en titre on tient beaucoup
de l'homme
ce qu'il représente pour la population
bien plus que son étiquette son
appartenance politique
ici je pense que c'est une sorte de
contestation plutôt une contestation des
avis de la politique que mène la france
par rapport au département du commerce
avec une politique de rechange
à mon avis il n'y a pas tellement de
politique de rechange mais n'empêche que
les gens contestent un peu comme vous et
comme les jeunes le font
actuellement un peu pour contester vous
refusiez sent toujours proposer quelque
chose en échange
les querelles de la gauche et celle de
la majorité arrive difficilement juste
en guadeloupe de la majorité aux
communistes
l'important ici est que les élections ne
bouleverse pas les rapports avec la
france
six otages du front polisario libérait
il ya deux mois se retourne aujourd'hui
contre la société minière qui les
employaient en lui demandant pour chaque
1 300 mille francs de dommages et
intérêts pour les préjudices physiques
et moraux qu'ils ont subi ferry noir
pour concorde
hier encore le supersonique a été obligé
de revenir au garage pour une petite
panne de deux heures de nombreux pilotes
de ligne souhaitent avoir davantage
d'appareils afin d'assurer plus aisément
la relève des avions défaillant une
nouvelle explosion dans la zone
sinistrée du 16e arrondissement à paris
mais là le gaz n'y est pour rien c'est
un transformateur l'électricité qui a
sauté
pas de blessés pas de dégâts mais à
nouveau une coupure d'électricité dans
ce quartier ravagé vendredi dernier et
puis dans deux semaines extension à
toute la france d'une expérience qui
semble avoir bien marché et qui avait
été lancée par olivier guichard il ya à
peu près un an la mise en place de
conciliateur dans quatre départements
destiné à alléger des tribunaux
surchargés
alain peyrefitte a fait le point
aujourd'hui c'est avec la centaine de
conciliateur qui existe déjà dans ces
quatre départements
et il semble que l'expérience soit
positive c'est un peu en quelque sorte
lefebvre disons la renaissance du juge
de frais l'ancien venue de frais où ils
n'ont pas la différence de paix le
conciliateur n'a pour l'instant aucun
statut de dépendance vis-à-vis du
pouvoir judiciaire ce n'est pas d'un
fonctionnaire très important les choisis
par les présidents de cours d'appel pour
ces garanties d'impartialité pour ses
qualités humaines
le conciliateur qui peut être saisie par
n'importe qui est un bénévole dont la
mission surtout et d'arbitrés puis
d'arriver à un accord à l'amiable entre
deux parties ça peut éviter le procès
bien souvent inutile mais c'est l'une
des parties refusent la conciliation ou
même d'exécuter l'accord déjà intervenu
et bien le conciliateur n'a pour
l'instant aucun moyen de contrainte
l'action de compte du conciliateur ne
s'exerce qu'en matière civile c'est à
dire en gros
lorsqu'il n'y a pas ni délit ni crime en
somme le conciliateur et l'homme où la
femme de bon sens puis avec nos
effectivement un conciliateur car je
crois qu'on a pas le droit de dire
conciliatrice a continué à faire madame
von arx pointe et qu'est ce que vous
faites dans la vie à part ça j'étais je
suis avocat honoraire ces cas
généralement des conciliateurs
ils ont une formation juridique la
moitié des conciliateurs entre une
formation juridique
alors quel genre de conflit vous avez à
résoudre à nous a fondé les tiges de
toute nature des litiges entre
propriétaires locataires des litiges
fonciers
c'est à dire des servitudes de passage
des bras de bandages des litiges entre
voisins mais aussi des litiges
concernant la famille pension
alimentaire en droit de visite garde
d'enfant ça vous pouvez nous résoudre à
notre époque il existe encore vraiment
le règlement à l'amiable
bien entendu les justiciables accorde
une importance primordiale à la
conciliation et la conciliation existe à
tous les stades de la procédure devant
tous les tribunaux
malheureusement elle échoue faute
d'avoir à lui consacrer le temps
nécessaire d'où l'originalité de
l'institution qui consiste à avoir une
voix subsidiaire en dehors de la
procédure normale devant le juge
classique
la conciliation est une voie de
dérivation où seule la conciliation est
possible et rien d'autre voilà ça
surtout en zone rurale ça pourrait être
possible en cognant peut s'appliquer
absolument partout le conciliateur a sa
place dans notre société
pensez vous que c'est l'expérience se
poursuit on sera obligé ramené à doter
le conciliateur de pouvoir car pour
l'instant on n'a aucun pouvoir si
quelqu'un vous dit non
s'entendre sur le mot pouvoir vous
parler
actuellement la pouvoir juridictionnel
qui signifie en fait un jugement est une
constante mais nous avons beaucoup mieux
nous conseillons nous proposons des
solutions de conciliation à deux
antagonistes qui lorsqu'ils sortent de
chez nous n'ont pas le sentiment d'avoir
perdu
nous les réponses et lyon et ils n'ont
pas perdu la partie
et ils ne sont pas des adversaires nous
sommes donc beaucoup mieux
nous avons donc plus de pouvoir le peu
d'entrain si vous avez un sourire de
conciliateur nouvelles arrestations
aujourd'hui au brésil des commissaires
fleury est accusée d'avoir participé à
des assassinats attribués au tristement
célèbre escalon escadrons de la mort il
faut ajouter que le commissaire fleury
est actuellement l'un des très hauts
responsables dans la hiérarchie
policière du brésil encore une nouvelle
attaque contre le dollar aujourd'hui il
n'est plus coté à paris iv 4 francs 79
le franc ne bouge pas et le franc suisse
lui n'arrête pas de grimper l'aurait
remarqué que tout au long de ses
bulletins de santé des monnaies depuis
le début de l'année je ne parle jamais
de la livre car la monnaie britannique
s'est sérieusement redressé ces derniers
temps l'économie de nos voisins anglais
aussi d'une façon générale les pour
autant tous les problèmes n'ont pas été
réglées d'un simple coup de bluff joe
dernière à londres
la première chose dont on s'aperçoit le
touriste en arrivant en grande bretagne
aujourd'hui et que la livre est cher les
cachemires chaussures et autres
vêtements anglais en donc pour lui
augmenter 10% en quelques mois la livre
est maintenant plus forte et tout le
monde en veut et en achète en espérant
qu'elle va monter en or comme les
actions qui grimpent également
bref les signes extérieurs de bonne
santé et de confiance retrouvée sont là
c'est donc que l'économie va mieux
c'est l'économie réelle ne va pas mieux
on n'a rien fait pour s'organiser pour
sports organise la production par
exemple à présent la production stagne
leur productive destin toutes les
pratiques de travail les pratiques
limitative qu'on avait il ya trois ans
il ya cinq ans sont toujours en place
des restes en place aussi longtemps
qu'il ya du chômage
cantona améliorer chômeurs on va pas
facilement dire aux gens bon on met un à
l'amont de rationalité une chose qu'on
diable pas donc pas forcément imminent
est vrai qu'il y en a pas un exemple
british l'élan géant de l'automobile
britannique qui assurait il ya sept ans
40% du marché et dans la sueur coulent
aujourd'hui que 24%
or l'entreprise a conservé tout son
personnel
il faudrait licencier un tiers des
employés dirigeants comme ouvrier avec
un million quatre cent mille chômeurs en
grande bretagne c'est exclu british
leyland née de la fusion d'une dizaine
de constructeurs fabriquent 14 modèles
différents
ronan fabrique une dizaine mais avec des
pièces et des moteurs souvent comme la
triumph son succès sur le marché
américain
on repasse une voiture est sortie de
l'usiné de spix depuis quatre mois les
ouvriers à qui ont demandé une
augmentation des cadences sont mises en
grève
plus il vient d'être fermée et 3000
employés sont au chômage
on construira la terre cet ailleurs la
rovère aussi est un succès on n'en
produit pas assez et la liste d'attenté
décourageante
en atten l'absurde des modèles anciens
continuent d'être fabriqué lui public
n'en veut plus et des milliers de
voitures roulent sur des parkings de
fortune par la moitié des britanniques
achètent des véhicules étrangers ou des
modèles britannique fabriqué en
allemagne par un constructeur américain
ford
les anglais ne veulent plus des
anglaises les étrangères outre meilleur
rapport qualité prix et une conduite
plus confortable
j'ai jamais essayé une voiture british
tel en est habituellement si vous
demandez une voiture anglaise
on ne peut pas vous la livrer tout de
suite à cause des grèves je cherche la
meilleure voiture pour les meilleurs
prix et renault me donne cela mais que
pensez-vous du slogan acheter
britannique
oui je sais j'ai vraiment honte mais
c'est comme ça
le taux de productivité de la grande
bretagne est le plus bas du monde
industrialisé
l'incohérence et la plus grande la
pologne a passé avec la grande bretagne
un contrat pour la construction de
treize bateaux
le gouvernement a confié de travail à
plusieurs chantiers en exigeant des
garanties sur les délais de livraison un
chantier
la prod rené ces garanties les
chaudronniers menaçant de faire grève
sur un presque brière archi des salaires
le gouvernement à retirer sa commande et
le chantier a dû licencier 1200 ouvriers
à 2 km dans un autre chantier que nous
avons pu visiter parce que celui la
marche bien
tous les ouvriers chaudronnier soudeur
ou électricien reçoivent le même salaire
ce qui se fait ici là pu se faire à côté
il ya pourtant les industriels heureux
des jeeps et exporte 95 % des camions de
chantier ils fabriquent et à une des
meilleure productivité d'euros seulement
l'entreprise est récente quatre ans le
matériel ultramoderne et la main
d'oeuvre peu abondantes
quand on demande au directeur les
raisons de la faiblesse britannique il
répond trop de dirigeants par ouvrier et
pas assez qualifié peu d'investissements
par ouvriers des syndicats trop
puissantes pas à cette souplesse et des
gens qui n'aiment pas le travail à la
chaîne
alors pourquoi la hausse subite de la
livre le pétrole le pétrole de la mer du
nord des milliards économisés qui ont
permis de rembourser les dettes de la
grande-bretagne lourd noir attirer les
capitaux et fait monter la lisent trop
au mois de janvier subitement la grande
bretagne a perdu de l'argent
la hausse de la livre a freiné les
exportations et fait peur aux touristes
l'économie est retourné dans la zone
rouge il va falloir s'attacher
maintenant à améliorer la productivité
un cauchemar en attendant le premier
ministre veut lancer une campagne
nationale
hp britannique nous ne demanderons pas
ce conducteur les raisons de son choix
ce n'est pas forcément pour supporter
l'économie britannique voilà un exemple
du volume d'informations dont nous
faisons en une journée mais parmi ceux
milliers de dépêches
il ya parfois des informations qui font
sursauter insiste elle là qui nous vient
d'autriche
c'est un anthropologue qui vient de
signer une étude au terme de laquelle on
apprend que si vous appartenez à un
groupe sanguin précis le groupe o
vous devriez vivre plus longtemps que
les autres dix pour cent de plus que les
personnes du groupe gue du groupe b
bardon et 20% de plus que celle du
groupe à laure martin a lorgné au
sérieux non je crois que ce n'est pas
sérieux
ma réponse est un peu nuancé parce que
depuis ce matin vous m'avez posé une
énigme et j'ai fait un tour de france
téléphoniques de tous les spécialistes
distinguent l'hérédité enfin presque
tour qu'est ce qu'ils vivent les disques
on ne peut rien dire on ne fait pas il
faut savoir que on ne sait pas si
appartenir au groupe a au groupe o
permet de vivre plus ou moins longtemps
et il trouve bien imprudent à monsieur
qui ose le dire de manière catégorique
les groupes sanguins sont connus depuis
70 ans
on les étudie sous toutes les coutures
n'a jamais rien trouvé qui permette de
dire ça jusqu'à présent alors je ne
m'avance pas plus que je crois que il y
as programme génétique propre à chaque
individu de la longueur de sa vie mais
que ce n'est pas forcément ayo vous êtes
des voleurs marché du groupe a du groupe
qui meurent le plus vite et vous du
groupe
oh je vais regarder ça qu'il y ait
quelqu'un nuland mais je suis du sexe
féminin qui vit plus longtemps que c'est
le sexe masculin
lorsque je voudrais dire un peu plus
sérieux concernant l'hérédité et le saut
c'est que si on ne connaît pas la
longueur de la vie avec le sang en
revanche on sait que certains groupes
mais pas forcément les groupes sanguins
de la transfusion d'autres groupes
beaucoup plus spécialisés
pré dispose d'un certain nombre de
maladies alors là on peut envisager
peut-être un peu de recrutement car cet
autrichien dit quelque part que il se
base sur le fait que quand ils étudient
des vieillards il y à beaucoup plus de
aux survivants que deux à et c'est
peut-être pour des raisons de maladie n
ont pas de longueur de la vie à ce père
qui est des groupes qui parle dispose
alors mais la voici une notion qu'il
faut bien retenir ce soir c'est que les
quatre groupes sanguins dont vous parle
tout le temps et que vous avez ici pour
la france 45 % de mon groupe
43 % de votre groupe et puis les
puissants 8% des français qui sont b
mais peut-être pour ça a des preuves les
vidéos en france ailleurs selon les
races la répartition est différente les
indiens d'amérique seront tous au et en
asie il ya plus de b alors ce que je
veux dire sa présence et qu'on a
tendance à parler de quatre groupes
sanguins sachez que maintenant c'est
commande uniquement pour la transfusion
sanguine
il en existe des centaines il est
rassuré elle y avait un tiercé à
vincennes c'est d'après midi arrivée le
10 le 3 et le 17
favier le ferra championne de france de
descente aujourd'hui à tignes c'est une
bonne performance car ce n'est pas une
spécialiste de cette épreuve football je
ne reviens pas sur les résultats de la
coupe de france d'hier sachez simplement
que dunkerque est le seul petit avoir
éliminé un gros mais il y avait aussi
pas réellement un match en retard en
championnat de france
saint-etienne a battu rouen 2-1 mais
vous allez le voir une victoire bien
amer à quand ça va mal 4e minute
on marque le premier but par cris gawker
23e minute rocheteau à terre entorse de
la cheville droite quinze jours d'arrêt
il sera disponible pour l'argentine
46e minute ici sarramagna reçoit la
riera mourrait sur sa jambe d'appui un
tacle meurtrier la radio décèlera
quelques minutes plus tard une double
fracture ouverte tibia péroné jeu
stéphanois pourra peut-être rejouer au
football
au début de la saison prochaine
peut-être janvion semble furieux
larbitre n'a même pas donné un
avertissement il y a deux semaines batna
été victime d'une mauvaise encore
saint-etienne gagnera 2 1
mais quelle triste soit bien les
rapports du tir scène parviennent à
l'instant où les découvre à l'instant
sur cet écran un peu plus de 5000 francs
dans l'ordre et un peu plus de 1000
francs dans un endroit différent tout
cela pour 5 francs les amateurs de la
franche à la planche à roulettes pardon
auront bientôt leur planchodrome à paris
sur le terrain des anciens abattoirs de
la villette travaux terminés en avril
c'est un sport qui est une vague
considérable puisqu'il ya déjà trois
magazines consacrés au skateboard le
dernier s'appelle tout simplement
skateboard la météo redoux général
depuis aujourd'hui avec quand même
quelques bavures notamment dans le
sud-ouest où les vents vous le voyez on
soufflaient à 140 kilomètres heure et on
dit racines et bon nombre d'arbres
toutes les rivières qui descendent des
pyrénées sont encore entre ses rangs il
faut le dire ne s'apaiseront pas pendant
le week-end surtout près de la manche et
de l'atlantique
à part cela bien la fin de semaine sera
presque prague printanière les
températures varieront entre 8 et 12
degrés il y aura quand même quelques
actes alternance d'averses et de rayons
de soleil mais pas de neige pas de
verglas ni de brouillard ça c'est sûr
pour refermer ce journal et après vous
avoir dit que gérard holtz sera là 23h30
pour un condensé l'actualité du jour
propose cet étonnant document du pape
recevant aujourd'hui les artistes du
cirque medrano et vous allez entendre un
moment paul 6 s'exclamer medrano medrano
en latin en italien ou en français
de toute façon c'est la même chose
écoutez bien regarder sur terre
mais